Đầu tiên em phải nói về các khu vực phát hiện fake news nói chung
thế giới ta làm cái gì
rồi mới đến là với tiếng Việt có những công trình nào
và giữa phát hiện fake news tiếng Việt với tiếng Anh có gì khác nhau
cái này đồng chí giả tổng minh nhưng mà thầy báo rất nhiều lần nó cũng thay đổi
cái bài báo 6 trang nó cũng nổi
họ cứ chưa lên được 6 trang là như thế nào
giữa tiếng Việt là công trình tiếng Việt
mà liên quan đến tiếng Việt đấy
còn những ông nào ở đây
Đây là 1. Tiếp theo là 1 nào?
Các vấn đề người ta đọc xong người ta nói là tiếng Việt đặc biệt.
Mình phải bỏ trong đầu cái gì đó chứ.
Mình phải đọc cái bài người ta nói gì về cái việc là phát hiện
cái việc tiếng Việt nó khác tiếng Anh là gì.
Người ta có cái gì để mà khác biệt.
Nhấn các em bổ sung các phương tích nhiều là phải nhớ là tác giả chính, các thầy, các giả thầy, các giả liên hệ cho các em.
Nhưng mà các em là tác giả chính, đấy là ý tưởng các em.
Thế thì giữa phần phát hiện kinh nghiệm tiếng Việt với những anh khác gì nhìn thấy nhau?
Thầy cũng chưa thấy, do chàng kể bài lẫn trong viết.
Những tác giả người ta làm cái gì? Người ta làm cái gì để mà tạo ra sự khác biệt?
Ngoài cái kiểu training bằng bố truyện tiếng Việt.
Và một trong các mô hình mà để xử lý tiếng Việt tốt nhất hiện nay đó là gì?
Em phải có một cái vai giọng nói về nó chứ
Phở vợt được trên dịch vụ dữ liệu gì hả Minh?
Dịch vụ dữ liệu của PIN tự do
Nó là dịch vụ dữ liệu gì?
Mình đến đây bây giờ chứ
Mình phụ sinh nó phải là như thế chứ
Không phải chỉ là lóc ghép mà nó chạy
Thì thấy là nó đang rất thiếu
Thế còn bây giờ nó có cái
Rõ ràng bây giờ em mở tư đề bài báo em là gì?
LINE cái gì?
LINE được cái CNN
Không phải, em mở lại bài báo này ra nào
Bây giờ em còn không nhớ được tên bài báo mình
Thì còn làm cái gì?
Mở cái bài báo ra
Mở cái bài báo cho thầy xem nào
Đấy là đưa vào khung hình nó được cho nó đúng
Mở cái bài báo cho anh xem
Sinh điển lên bằng nó đâu phải đơn giản như em nghĩ đâu
Cái tên này
Ít nhất là khi thầy gửi cái tên này
Em phải cảm nhận cho là tại sao thầy gửi cái tên này
Cái chỗ nào của em nói thì khỏa vật
Thầy cho thầy nói chỗ nào khỏa vật cả
Như vậy ở đây là khỏa vật trong cái môi quan trọng của cái sơ đồ này
Thì cái multi-scale đó chỗ nào cũng vừa rồi
Thầy cho thầy chặt cái đó cho cả multi-scale đâu cả
Cuối cùng của nó là cái fusion
dựa trên hệ thống tổng
Đấy là những thành phần quan trọng mà cần được nhấn mạnh ở đây
Chả có ý nghĩa gì cả
Qua chi phầy của em thì em hiểu là em chả lắm được
Xin lỗi nhưng mà
Làm sao mà làm music được
Cái phần
Cái phần sơ đồ đâu
Đọc vào cái tên bên trái em chả có ý nghĩa gì cả
Đọc bên trái thì nó hoàn toàn lắp ghép gì gì
Nhưng mà cái quy thuật này
Phương pháp để dựng ra là phương pháp
Thì mình phải nói rõ được cái logic đó là cái gì
Đấy
Cái gì, cái ý nghĩa của những cái multi-scale nó chỗ nào của em cũng không hề nói như thế nào cả
Cái fusion ở chỗ này cũng không hề nói như thế nào cả, nó chỉ phối biến sư đồ rồi, sư đồ ai để ý
Chưa kể một đồng bóp nước làm loss, gì đấy, quan trọng tiếp từ đấy, cũng chưa thấy nói ở chỗ nào cả
Mình nói một lời, ai cũng cho vào tay rồi
Em thường nói với em là, cái sư đồ mình đưa ra rồi, mình phải hiểu nó
Mình điểm nhấn nó là cái gì đó, chính nó là cái gì mình phải, nhất là một cái hình đầu dòng bên trái bên này
Em không phải hình đầu dòng bên trái, em biết, em chưa hiểu
Mục tiêu trong trình bày chẳng có mục nào
Nếu mà nhìn vào câu đề xuất như này thì ai đồng ý cho em rồi
Nhánh bên trái, nhánh bên phải, 2 nhánh, nhánh bên trái, nhánh bên phải
Tại sao là 2 nhánh? Tại sao lại đối vào?
Thích gì cả? Có nghĩa là các em đang làm củ công
Là làm rap chả hiểu được cái music là cái gì
Tại sao không là 2 nhánh?
Tại sao lại là 2 nhánh fusion?
Bây giờ là bao nhiêu thời gian rồi, cái đấy em phải tập trung vào để trình bày cho nó mạch lạc
Nói em cái bài này của em là bài quan trọng
Nếu mà không được chấp nhận bài này thì sẽ rất ảnh hưởng đến đầu bằng của suy nghĩ tiếp tới
Kết quả có rồi nhưng vấn đề là mình sao nấu nó lên
Nội các em tập trung thêm vào
Thầy nói trước là năm nay là tỷ lệ chấp nhận rất thấp
Nên là cố gắng lên
Chưa kể vấn đề của mình là vấn đề lớn nhất, điểm yếu nhất của mình đây là dữ liệu
Khi dữ liệu này yếu thì mình phải đi vào logic để giải thích
Cái gì thầy nói hôm nay là bản thân hiểu về dữ liệu
Tất cả các em phải suy nghĩ lại
Đừng để thầy phải nói lại một lần nữa
Tiết báo cũng chưa cooler gì mà có vài cái câu text, cái phần bàn luận có gì mà ít hơn cả cái thông tin ở trong bản
Cái bản kết quả có bao nhiêu thứ để mà nói, so sánh, anh A, anh B, anh A đặt chân gì, anh B đặt chân gì, như vậy hơn cái gì cũng tỷ lưu để biết mình cũng chưa cooler gì
Làm sao các em tiết báo không nghĩ ra được thì phải đọc các bài bản báo khác tương tự của các em ta làm như thế nào
Ngay từ đầu thì các thầy cũng cầm tay chỉ được các em rồi đâu
Nhưng cái đấy các em phải tự, chỉ có biến
Những thứ thầy nói hôm nay mà các em không thay đổi
thì không bao giờ các em vào được những hội thảo tốt và tài sản tốt
và hiển và sắp tới bảo vệ cầu vàng
Các thầy chấp nhận cho em nếu các em trình bày kế hoạch này
Các thầy kết quả báo của thầy là bài cũng rất nét
Rồi em cũng thử ghép cái phần file của họ vào cái phần
cái nghiên cứu dữ liệu của em cũng rất nét
Cho em xin trình bày kết quả của experiment của em
Tiến trúc của họ thì em xin trình bày lại
Tiến trúc của họ thì phần bài RedNet thì bao gồm 2 nhánh trên 2 nhánh này
Bao gồm phần nhánh Temporal thì họ sử dụng mô hình Way2Vet
Cụ thể Modal đây là XLR P-Chain
Cộng thêm một khối Red Detection để nhấn mạnh vào các cái vùng thời gian có hơi thở
Nhánh tần số thì sử dụng một mô hình có tên là DFIM
Sau đó họ cross 2 nhánh liên lạc
Nhánh DFIM sẽ đóng vai trò Q
Tức là nhánh tần số sẽ đóng vai trò Q
Nhánh thời gian sẽ đóng vai trò là K
Tức là nhánh tần số sẽ đi tìm thông tin từ nhánh thời gian
Thứ 2 của bài này là phần hàm project loss
2 cái phần này thì các bạn hướng dẫn cho đề bản sử dụng không?
Hướng dẫn cho đề bản sử dụng của em thì nó chỉ có nhánh temporal
Em sử dụng phần n là XSR bản 1B tính tham số
Thì đầu tiên thì sau khi em dừng lại thì kết quả em ra được là 2.65 và bf 6.2
Thì nó rất khác so với kết quả họ công bố là 1.15 và 1.87
em có kiểm tra lỗi thì nó sẽ, em có xem lại cái hình thì nó bị overfix ngay từ các cái pop-up đầu
tức là hàng của nó tự nhiên nó tăng gọn lên ở Validate
thì em có kiểm tra lại thì các cái cấu hình của tác giả thì là tác giả đặt learning rate phần front-end rất tấp
em đặt là 1M-5 thì tác giả đặt riêng cái phần front-end này là 1M-6
Tổng thời em có bỏ đi cái phần Correct và tổng thời là ở cái Action A thì em đang để là trên trên 2 GPU
Chắc rằng ở đây họ chỉ trên trên 1 GPU và nó back side là 10
Thì em có sửa lại các cái cấu hình trên thế thì kết quả em ra được tốt hơn
Bộ 2021 cao đây thì họ đạt 33 của DF, họ đạt 4,31, tuy nhiên cái kết quả này thì nó cũng chưa sắp sau khi được đảm bảo, đảm bảo họ công bố cái tập DF của họ là 1,87.
Thì em cũng, các giả cũng có nói là họ sử dụng kết quả trung bình của 3 trạng số EBOX nhất thì em cũng có thử trích ra lần này kết quả.
Rồi, em dừng lại cái bài họ thôi được không?
Rồi, gần đây em đang chỉ mấy phần chỗ em dừng lại, thì em cũng cộng lại 3 cái EBOX họ đạt tốt nhất.
Kết quả trên 1.3, 1.3, 1.1 là Epoch tốt nhất của họ
Còn kết quả dưới là em có tổng lại 3 Epoch
Câu này tham số trung bình 3 Epoch nhất
Được là 2.163 và 5.059
Thì phần trung bình tham số này nó không thực sự tốt
Bằng phần Epoch nhất
Cái Excalibur tiếp theo thì em có thử dùng Codec
Vì là đặc điểm của tầm 2021 DF
Về đề pháp DF thì họ có sử dụng các codec như là codec như khi mình upload trên các cái nền tảng mạng xấu MP3 các thứ
Thì em có sử dụng codec là sử dụng sản xuất trên 5% và trên và bí rết là ném mạch 16 và 32k
Kết quả của công ty y tức là 2.5.5.1 XTNB
Thì em đoán ở đây cái kiểu cố địch có mạnh
Như là nén có mạnh và sát xuất hấp dụng trên tập trên nhiều 5%
Thì nó sẽ làm mất thông tin của tập trên
Thì em thực hiện từ 4, hiện B thì em có hấp dụng
Cần cố địch nó nhẹ hơn thì em chỉ để sát xuất là 30%
Và beat rate thì em cho cái việc nén của nó giảm đi
Kết quả này ca tốt 1,34 và 4,17 so với lần trước là 4,31, tức là tập DF đã giảm khoảng 15 và 14%.
Thì điều này cho thấy là công nghiệp codec nhưng mà ở mức vừa phải thì nó không bị quá ảnh hưởng đến tập LA.
Thì bình thường trước đây em có làm thì sử dụng codec, do là phần nghiên cứu trước em có sử dụng codec rồi nhưng mà nó phá kết quả rất là mạnh.
và những bài nghiên cứu trước em được chuẩn bị LLA
cho nên là kết quả công bố nghiên cứu trước em không sử dụng codec
thì lần này em target vào thêm cả tập 2021DF nữa
có thể sử dụng cái tạo lại trên nghiên cứu họ
thì ở cái codec nhẹ này kết quả em thấy khá là ok
kết quả không trung bình lại thì tốt hơn
so với việc không sử dụng codec ở thí nghiệm tiếp theo
Như em đã trình bày thì tập trưng của cái bài này của họ thì họ có sử dụng thêm một cái nhánh tần số nữa
Thì em có thử cắt đi cái nhánh tần số này của họ
Thì kết quả ra trên tập 2021 là 6,15 và 6,69
Tức là tăng rất nhiều so với việc có nhánh tần số
Thì điều này cho thấy là cái việc sử dụng nhánh tần số nói chung
hay là cục DF-IM để chọn đặc trưng thương hiệu tần số riêng
cho thấy đóng góp đáng kể vào kết quả của chúng
Cục DF-IM ở đây, cơ bản họ sử dụng lớp CC-Convolution
có thêm cooling, Magnon
Ở nhãn DF-IM này, em thấy có một phần gap
thì mình có thể tối ưu hơn so với cái bản của họ
Cùng là cái extension F
đây là cái extension cuối của em trên cái bài RedNet này
thì bài gốc của họ sử dụng tích RedR
bản 300M thì em có sử dụng một cái mô hình quy trên mới của Facebook
thì cái cơ bản nó vẫn chút nó vẫn giống với chú bếp tôi nhưng mà
họ train trên nhiều ngôn ngữ hơn
tưởng cái phần ngôn ngữ trên đa dạng hơn
và tham số của mô hình này thay cho XLSR 300M
Tại mô hình này cho những kết quả DF ra tốt hơn hẳn
Tức là tại đây DF giảm từ mức tốt nhất
XPSD 4,17 là số được 2,46
Tuy nhiên là nhánh LA tăng lên 3,58
Tuy nhiên đây cũng là mốc trên tiêu tập 2021 DF, 2016 là kết quả rất tốt mà nghiên cứu trước
mình cũng chưa đạt được
Thì cái này em cũng sẽ nghiên cứu để em thay
bởi vì theo như em thử nghiệm thì cái bài audio feedback này khá phụ thuộc vào khách hàng
Thì đáng hiểu là hai người cũng giữ sức khác nhau đúng không?
Đa số các công trình tốt hơn này thì còn hơn kia
Đúng không?
Đấy là cái gần thức thương kỹ đấy
Thì cái tính hướng nghiên cứu tích cảm của mình là mình phải làm thế nào
cho cộng trung bình hai cái data set này là tốt nhất
Chứ không chỉ là một bộ data set
Tôi cũng đang nghĩ, đang nghe cái thái niệm là chứng cất
Tức là người ta có cái môi nó tốt quá rồi
Nó lớn, người ta có thể riêng một cái môi nhỏ
Nhưng mà lấy luôn các kiến thức ở môi to này
Không phải vừa lại
Để đọc thêm cái nào
Cũng là một cái hướng đi
Có thể trong trường hợp mà nó được quá ốc
Nhưng mà có thể lấy để sau một tí
Thế thôi đi
Thì em có, phần bài thách thì cơ bản là thế
Thì em có tổng hợp lại ở cái bản này
các cái bài học rút ra
thì em cũng có thử nối
Đấy, thì cái số liệu này đã phải là tốt nhất
trong các cái công trình khác
Thế là 2,65
à xin lỗi, cái 1,33
đã phải tốt nhất chưa?
so với EOA em
Chưa thiệt
số ta là phải 2
Còn thằng DF
DF thì 4,5
Em chưa cho cái F ở đây
thì cái DF 246 là tốt nhất
thì cái DF 246 cũng chưa phải là
là tốt nhất trên các mô hình
nhưng mà tuy nhiên nó hơi...
Thế thì tại sao chọn Grand Net ở lòng?
Thứ nhất là bởi vì em thấy hướng đi của họ
nó cũng phù hợp với các hướng đi tiếp cận tiếp theo của mình
tức là họ nối, họ sử dụng Coordination
giữa hai nhánh tần số và nhánh thời gian
thì cái nhánh thời gian tư bản chất thì mình đã có rồi
thì cái nhánh tần số cũng như là cái chất thầy vạch ra cho em
thì hẳn như là các việc trích xuất, các chân thủ công
thì nó đều tập trung vào cái việc là biểu diễn của tổng số đấy
thì sau này mình có thể bổ sung thêm các cái thành phần
Đấy phải chỉ lan tăng thôi, kép đi
Thì em có thử ghép cái funnel của BNS vào cái phần backend
của cái SACAP, cái nghiên cứu chất
thì ở cái nghiên cứu chất đây thì mình đã đạt được là 0.85
thì mụn LA và bún được 0.35
Tốt nhất là 0.85 và 3.53
Thì sau khi thay vào thì em cũng có sửa lại, tức là đầu tiên là cái đầu da của mình so với tầng front end thì lần trước đây là 21 thì để mà phù hợp với đầu da mới thì là 32.
Tức là đầu vào của bánh ảnh nướng cũng thay đổi từ 2-0-1 feature xuống còn 3-2 feature
Thì kết quả đạt được tệ hơn là 2.18 và 5.76
Những phần này là em cũng chưa tích hợp feature loss vào
Em có suy đoán là kết quả thấp hơn này một phần có thể do không tích hợp
Cái thứ hai là bản chất mình dùng bản 1B, còn cái bản này mình ghép vào là họ dùng IPR bản 300M
Cơ bản nó cũng ít tham số, yếu hơn. Thì cái này cũng cần em sẽ nghiên cứu thêm
Cuối cùng thì em có thích hợp các cái Feature Log, các cái Concept Log như họ nêu trong bài
Và em áp dụng codec nhẹ như cái kết quả áp dụng từ bài trước là cái codec mv3 nhẹ 30%
và sử dụng mô hình mới của nút, tức là mô hình 1S, 1B làm phần encoder.
Thì kết quả ở đây thì nó cũng có tốt hơn là 1.2 và 21.5.0
tuy nhiên là nó cũng chưa tốt bằng cái mô hình ban đầu của mình.
Thì phần này thì em đề xuất cái hướng tiếp theo.
Thì cái phần bộ trị xuất ở cái nguyên thời gian của họ em thấy là cũng khá là trang trúc,
nó cũng khá là bổ sung nhiều vào cuộc này
tuy nhiên là cái phần trích xuất
đặc trưng ở cái nguyên tầm số
đang rất ít
nó còn đúng một khối
DFM và chỉ sử dụng CC Volution thôi
còn các cái nhánh thời gian
thì có thể mình sẽ tiếp thu của họ
thì lấy một số gap
thì có thể mình cải thiện
Như vậy là họ report là
cái NDF là họ đạt được 1.87 đúng không?
thì mình chạy lại thì cao nhất
mình chỉ được 2.46 đúng không?
Các bảng bên trái, lúc tháng 7 và tháng kia 1.15
Các lần ECW mô hình của họ thì chỉ đạt là 1.34 và 1.17
Còn đây là cái F thì là do em thay cái phân anh khác mà mấy em mới làm
Thì đấy, cái bảng bên trái là những cái công trình mới nhất từ gì đấy đúng không?
Đúng, bảng bên trái là những cái mới nhất
Những cái em nói là không phải bao nhiêu nó nằm ở công trình nào?
Đây được, ngay bên đầu, EOI được
Cái này là tôi thích của nó là 1.49
Nên em phóng to 1 chút, phóng to cái mảng 4 1 chút
Như vậy cái thang 282 đã làm được 0.2, 0.15, đế khoảng khoảng 1.87
Nhưng mà trước đó đã có thang dài 1.49 rồi
Đây họ công nhận họ là SOTA ở trung bình
Tức là trung bình giữa 2 tầm LVDF thì không trung bình 2 này nào
À, rồi rồi, trung bình, đấy là 1 cách
Thế cái này nó cũng có thể chứng minh được là mô hình của mình nó
Cái hướng đấy mình nghĩ là mình sẽ tối ưu ở hướng này
Chứ không chỉ tối ưu sinh mục thì tập ta đã xếp rồi
Ok, ok, ok
Nghĩ là đây các star nó đến rất rồi
Bài này cũng ra vào năm 2006
Mới nhất rồi
Bạn này nó chơi kiểu trung bình
Vì là chơi từng thằng thì nó không ngoại
Thế nhưng mà nó chơi trung bình
Nghĩ nó phải tìm được cái gì đấy để
Một cái cửa để nó
Rồi bây giờ cái bài báo kia
Thì hướng anh như thế nào nhỉ
Nghĩ bài này họ cho em chỉnh sở đến là một cái tính hướng tốt
Các tính hướng ở đây
Em cũng
ở đây họ yêu cầu mình giải thích việc
thứ nhất là bổ sung các thang số liên quan đến
mình xử lý xem cách hỏi hoặc phản biệt
trong kinh nghiệm mình có bị phải làm gì
các table manager
report hết
mình nhé
report hết những cái này
để mình chứng minh mình không fake
tổng hợp lại là
thứ nhất bổ sung các thang số
và bổ sung tại sao mình chọn lại
thì chọn các tham số như là phút 1 tuần x, mình đặt tham số R18
thì cái bổ sung tham số thì chắc chắn là phải bổ sung rồi
Còn cái ý dạy tại sao lại chọn các tham số này thì
em nghĩ là chỉ có chạy Appliation Study thôi
Ờ, mình chưa có, họ đang bổ sung đấy
Thì chỉ có chạy Appliation Study thôi
Cái thứ 3 là...
Codec
Codec này thì mình cũng phải chạy Appliation Study thôi
Thì có kết quả, có kết quả ra thì cũng sẽ xử lý chung được.
Chỗ này em, về ba em cũng vừa chạy rồi.
Tức là tác giả review 1 này thì họ yêu cầu...
Nói chung họ yêu cầu khá nhiều những phần là tại sao họ chọn số này, số này thì những cái
này em nghĩ hầu hết là đều kể
Nhưng mua chứng minh thì phải chạy Ablation Study của Zoom
Vì view 2 thì tại sao lại chọn Free Layer là 9
Ở cái phần Ablation Study thì họ có nói là em không được chọn cái chỉ số K
Free Layer là 9 dựa trên kết quả 2021 LA
trên tập VAL, trên tập đầy giá mà phải chạy trên tập Depth
như thế kết quả của mình mới đúng
cái này em cũng sẽ sửa lại
thứ hai là cái chỗ mình nhận là SOTA 0.83
nhưng mà có một bài ACID 0.82 thì mình nhận SOTA nó cũng chưa đúng
cái này em lập luận với em trong bài thì em dựa vào một cái bài khác họ re-implement lại
thì kết quả của bài SOTA nguồn trung nhất này không được như vậy
tuy nhiên các giả nêu ra làm như thế cũng không đúng
thì cái này anh nghĩ là mình chỉ nói giả tránh không nhận SOTA nữa đoạn này
Cứ giải thích thường tiên nhé
Ý họ đang nói mình nói sai nhé
Phần thứ 3, ý ký thứ 3 là
Các hệ thống chưa tách ra đồng bọc của khối XLR Funnel
Sử dụng bên trên thì phải có thêm những cái như là
best run, min, những thứ đấy
ở đây trung bình là giá trị tốt nhất đấy
Để thấy rõ sự khác biệt giữa 0.5 và 0.7
Thật sự khác biệt, hiểu gì không?
Thứ thứ 3 họ nêu là
các experiment mình chưa nêu rõ
là các cái đóng góp của các cái khối Funnel
Ví dụ như là việc chọn phai tool, Fiji, Helix hay là cái mô hình kỹ thuật là thật size
Thì cái này cũng rất là nếu mà muốn rõ ràng thì ta chạy lạc các cái thông thần này ta chạy lạc
Nói chung là cũng phải chạy population study khá nhiều
Thứ 4 là liên quan đến đánh cặp các chỉ số như cái reviewer 1
Thứ 5 thì nó liên quan đến việc...
Mình nói về là cái góc của những hiệu năng đó chính là cái vector orientation đấy
Đấy là một cái cấu trúc tổng hợp nhiều thành phần ấy
Thế nhưng mà trong cái thí nghiệm và giải thích mình chưa đề cập gì cả
Nguyễn Trúc này em nói chỗ nào?
Cái này đúng là em thiếu, em thiếu ở đây là chưa
Cái này cũng em có giải thích nhưng mà giải thích ở dạng lý thuyết thôi
Em chưa có experiment, experiment cái này thì
Anh nghĩ là sẽ phải chạy Atlas, Atlas to Stunny với cả Caddx, Dock so sánh, đưa các cái chỉ số so sánh.
Thì anh nghĩ đó là cái reviewer này đánh giá cũng đúng.
Thì có nêu ra là mình đã chạy trên 3 lần chạy độc lập.
Tuy nhiên là mình lại fix cái random seed, à mình lại cố định cái random seed.
Thì muốn gọi là independent thì cái...
Đúng rồi, phải khác nhau chứ.
Vâng, cái này thì đúng.
Cảm ơn các bạn đã theo dõi, hẹn gặp lại các bạn trong những video tiếp theo.
Ngoan đến khả năng bypass của em thì đến nay thì khả năng bypass của em nó khá là cao, cũng là một lý do là do mình thêm các hàm XPI, mẫu bốc nó ít hơn các hàm khác nó rất là nhiều.
Vì thế là em có vừa rồi quan trọng là em có chỉnh lại những lượng.
Ngoan đến các số lượng hàm XPI có thể thêm vào cho các mẫu mới và cũng mới chạy lại thôi thì cũng đã giảm tương đối rồi.
cũng đang điều chỉnh cái tham số đấy để cho cái kỷ lệ bypass của cái mẫu này sinh ra nó chẳng có các kỷ lệ
thế này thầy Trung xem là 2 quả, thầy Trung giúp cùng anh Nam xem là tại sao
mình cũng chấp nhận được đâu, cái D2 gan với cái AE này mà bây giờ kết quả toàn tồi hơn cả mau gan gốc thì
cái 2 cái chấp nhận mình, cái kỷ lệ bypass của mình, cái kỷ lệ bypass nó tạo chiếc thằng số 3 mà mau gan toàn không hết
Nên là nó trốn được hết. Tất nhiên là cái kết quả này.
Theo cái code này của em thì vẫn là cái code gốc.
Nhưng mà tại vì lồng ép thêm một cái module liên quan đến giá trị đúng mẫu.
Chắc chắn là có vấn đề.
Em đang khóa xe lãi. Cái này mình mang ra rồi.
Nhưng sao nó ở x trong vớt?
À đây là cái bảng liên quan đến.
Cái câu kia, cái câu của nó x trong vớt.
Tức là cái chỉ số hay cả bất tìm là tất cả không.
Nó là gì nhỉ, cái tỷ lệ phát hiện ra cái thằng OTCO này nó thấp mà
90% người ta không phát hiện được, nó chạy qua hết
Mẫu sinh ra thì tốt hơn sao?
Vấn đề thằng Morgan tốt hơn hẳn, sao có cái thằng Nam này xuất này này
Thằng Bình mình xuất thì mình...
Đúng không, cái gì, cái trái của tác xếp đánh giá nó có làm cái gì nữa
Tức là ở đây cái đóng inbox của mình tức là liên quan đến giá, liên quan đến cái tỷ lệ hàng API thêm nào
Cái này chỉ là cái phụ thôi. Cái này phân tích thêm. Sau khi có kết quả kia, mình phân tích thêm cái này.
Thế cái nào là chính? Cái kia mới là chính. Cái đâu đó chính thì cái kia mới là chính.
Thì hôm nay em xin thả lấy tiền nào?
Nó thu 1 trăm rồi sau đó phát cái gì nữa?
Nó thu 1 trăm rồi thì nó thu cái bài đó.
Trên cái bài gốc của họ là không có hiện ra hả?
Mở cái bài gốc ra.
Không biết mức về không như thế.
Hãy subscribe cho kênh La La School Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Đây là cái bảng góc của vĩnh vụ dưới này không ạ?